CHRIS BANES: Hi,
I'm Chris, and I
work at the Developer
Relations team at Google.
How would you like to
improve the look of your app
using the new Material
styler in Android L?
I'm going to show you how to do
this, along with my Banesy Top
Tips.
But first, here's
an introduction
to the new Material
design principles.
They've been created to
work across all devices,
from Android to the web.
And they're our comprehensive
guide for the visual, motion,
and interaction design for apps.
Now, to go on this journey,
we need a sample app.
We'll be using XYZ
Reader, which you
may remember from the show,
Android Design Action.
Now this app already
utilizes some
of things which you associate
with a good Android app.
Things like branding
for color on the action
bar, responsive touch feedback,
the use of standard type sizes,
prominent use of imagery,
both on the list,
and the detail UIs.
Now, our goal is to
make it look like this.
So let's get started.
Now, the first step
is to change its theme
to inherit from one of
the new Material themes
available in Android L.
There are equivalent Material
themes for the majority
of the Holo themes
which your apps are using.
Our sample app uses
DarkActionBar as its base
theme, so here we will
create a new styles XML file
in the values v21
folder, redefining
our existing Theme.Bacon theme
to inherit from the Material
version of the
DarkActionBar theme.
And after we've done
that, we'll have
something that looks like this.
Now, there are a number of
things you may notice here.
The action bar is now
more colorful by default,
and this ties in
with the encouraged
use of color in your UIs.
Clickable items now receive
the new infill touch feedback.
And overall, the
metrics have changed,
as space is now
treated differently.
So we haven't yet customized
the Material theme,
so let's go ahead and add
our branding color back
into the app.
But before we do that, let's
take a step back, and see
what we need to do
with Holo to achieve
this color customization.
Here is a small section
of our styles file.
We're only customizing
the action bar,
and you can already see that the
main theme is pretty complex.
If you also start customizing
any of the standard widgets--
such as Button or Any
Text, your styles file
can easily become
hundreds of lines long.
Now, there are obvious
downsides to this.
The fact that it's hard
to maintain and update,
but you also need
to bundle colorized
Drawables in your
app, such as these,
which adds unnecessary bloat.
Now luckily, there are tools
such as Action Bar Style
Generator, and
Android Holo Colors,
which can make this pretty easy.
But wouldn't it be nice
if it could do this
without having to put
so much work into it?
Now, the good news is that
the new theming functionality
in Android L allows
you to accomplish this
without needing to bundle those
Drawables or style definitions.
This new functionality allows
you to declare your color
scheme in your main style.
And this is done by setting new
attributes, the most important
two being colorPrimary
and colorPrimaryDark.
colorPrimary is your
app's main branding color,
and is used by the app bar,
scrolling edge effects,
and other built-in widgets.
colorPrimaryDark, as
the name suggests,
is a darker variant
of colorPrimary,
and is used to color
the contextual action
bar, amongst other things.
So back to our sample
app, our styles file
becomes the following,
with colorPrimary
and colorPrimaryDark
set to two colors
from resources-- bacon
and crispy bacon.
And after that, our sample
app looks like this.
You can see that the
action bar and edge effects
have changed color to
fit our color scheme.
MALE SPEAKER: Banesy's Top Tip.
[BANG]
CHRIS BANES: Internally,
a lot of this
is allowed for the new
Drawable tinting functionality.
This is a great
new feature, which
allows you to easily recolor
Drawables at run time.
Here's a Drawable defined XML,
which specifies a red tint,
using another Drawable
as the source.
There's also the setTint
method on Drawable,
to achieve the same thing.
Now, the next step is to look
at the layout of the app.
The Material design
principles introduce a new way
to think about the
space in your app,
using baseline grids and
keylines to promote consistency
across the system as a whole.
A level down from
that, we will now
also provide detailed
guides about space, padding,
and overall metrics.
The most commonly used
containers and elements,
things such as lists,
grids, and buttons.
Now it's important to note
that for the most part,
these metrics are not
provided by the framework,
meaning that you
need to implement
them yourselves in your layouts.
We also now have a set
of standard type styles
and scales.
Each one of these
has been chosen
to balance content density with
reading comfort for the user.
Combined with the
new Roboto font,
used in Android L-- which
is rounder and wider--
these styles should give your
text content greater clarity.
So back to our sample app.
We're going to convert our
list into a grid, which
will allow our imagery
to be more prominent
and add quick visual
comprehension.
To do that, we're going to
take the grid container guide,
and apply it to
our list of meats.
Each container
guide tends to have
a number of different
variants, to allow flexibility
for the type of content
you're trying to show.
Here, we are going to use
the two long variants.
There are other variants in
the grid component guide, which
differ on the
number lines of text
or graphics each item displays.
So let's look more in
depth at the guide.
Each item displays
a square image,
along with two lines of
text, which can either
overlay the image, or be inline.
It specifies the type
of fonts and sizes,
along with your four div
spacing for all items.
In this variant, we have
two options for text sizes.
You have a 16 sp for the first
line, and 12 for the second,
or 14 sp for both.
Now, which one you use depends
on the relative importance
of your text.
And after doing that, this
is what it will look like.
Each item is issued a
pass for the increased
size of the imagery, and we've
minimized the amount of text
which needs to be displayed.
Now obviously, we have only
gone through one screen here,
and most apps will
have more than this.
You will need to read
through the design guide,
applying all of the appropriate
layout guides to your app's UI.
MALE SPEAKER: Banesy's Top Tip.
[BANG]
CHRIS BANES: You are going to
be using the standard keylines
a lot in your apps, so instead
of hard coding the values
in your layouts, make sure
you are declaring them
in your dimension resources.
Here are three to
get you started,
but there are many more
which can be added here.
And now we move on to imagery.
Now, imagery is one of the key
principles in the new design
language.
It should be used to show
relevance, convey information,
and generally delight the user.
Now, for this
section, we're going
to focus on the detail
screen of the app.
The current layout
ought to use imagery
of its full bleed banner image.
But we're going
to improve things
by making it more immersive.
The way we're
going to do that is
by using the translucent
status bar functionality, which
was added in Android KitKat.
Now, doing this allows us to
make the app bar translucent
when the content is scrolled
all the way to the top.
And this allows the
imagery to bleed
into the outer [INAUDIBLE].
We then bring the app
bar back into view
when the image and title
have scrolled out of view.
Now, this technique
is not reliant
on any new functionality
in Android L,
so you can use it
on past versions.
And indeed, many apps in
Google Play already do this,
you may have seen it in
the Google Play Music app.
We have also brought the
title and subtitle into view,
or move them out of the image,
and into their own contrasting
layout, again, using
the app's primary color
to emphasize our brand.
And finally, the
body text has been
tweaked to match
the body topographic
style from the design guide.
So finally, here's
our end result again.
As a quick recap, our
branding color is now
used throughout the
app, both of the screens
are using the new base
grids and keylines,
and we have emphasized our
imagery on the detail UI
by making it more immersive.
MALE SPEAKER: Banesy's Top Tip.
[BANG]
CHRIS BANES: Are
you wondering how
to implement a fade-in action
bar with translucent status
bar?
Well, Roman Nurik posted a
great Android developers protip
on exactly this recently.
As part of that, he wrote
the DrawInsetsFrameLayout,
which makes it really easy.
You can grab the code
from his GitHub gist.
But the fun doesn't
stop there, so
to help your app
reach the sky, here
are some more things we
have added for this release.
Activity scene
transitions, which
allows you to use the
scene and transitions
API when you're transitioning
from activity to activity.
RecyclerView is our next
generation adaptive view,
intended to replace
ListView and GridView.
RecyclerView has
been designed so
that the logic for laying
out items is pluggable,
meaning that you now have
complete control over how
your items are laid out.
Android has gone 3D, with
elevation and translation
Z. So as well as being to move
views in the x- and y-axis,
you can now move in the z-axis.
And this allows your views
to come away from the screen,
casting a real time shadow
to create depth to UIs.
And finally, floating
action buttons
are a new type of button
which are reserved
for your most important actions.
They're recognizable
as a circular icon
which floats above your UI.
So thanks for watching, now
show us what you can do.